average millionaire is only the average  dishwasher dressed in a suit  this month we're looking at a tale of  two cities down and out in Paris in  London by George Orwell this is an  extremely personal memoir of his time as  a struggling writer in the 1920s so  George Orwell well he said he's a  British writer and he was actually born  into the middle-class family his parents  expected him after school he would go to  university get a very stable job at his  sole he was a writer and he had  completely different idea to that he  comes to Paris and the first thing  happens is he gets robbed  he becomes a philosopher about what it  means to be poor and basically  completely disenfranchised from society  the book ends and very movingly with  this defense of the [ __ ] and the  defense of the beggar I would recommend  it for teenagers creative people and  anyone who's a fan of George Orwell  because it is his first novel